President Trump has tried to walk back
some of the explosive comments he made
about his willingness to accept dirt on
a political opponent from a foreign
government without feeling an obligation
to notify law enforcement the comments
raised red flags among Democrats and
some Republicans we judge a Jang is at
the White House with more I think you
might want to listen I don't this
nothing wrong with listening President
Trump said he would not refuse dirt on a
political rival if another country
offered it even though it is a crime for
a campaign to knowingly accept anything
valuable from a foreign government you
want that kind of interference in our
elections it's not an interference they
have information I think I'd take it if
I thought there was something wrong I go
maybe to the FBI
if I thought there was something wrong
FBI director Christopher Rea has said
the right thing to do in every case is
to report it and that's something that
the FBI would want to know about the FBI
director is wrong the controversy is
unfolding as Congress continues to
investigate Russian meddling in the 2016
campaign Donald Trump jr. testified
about meeting with a russian lawyer
promising damaging information about
hillary clinton i will tell you this
russia if you're listening then
candidate Trump once asked Moscow to
investigate his opponent there was an
assault on our democracy House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi said the president is
inviting foreign governments to play a
role in our elections president gave us
once again evidence that he does not
know right from wrong it's a very sad
thing even Republicans are struggling to
defend mr. Trump Senator Lindsey Graham
a faithful ally called him out yeah I
think it's a mistake I think I think
it's a mistake of law I don't want to
send a signal to encourage this we
judging CBS News the White House